[Music]
a few of the Avengers assembled in China
yesterday for the Shanghai premiere of
infinity rule the newest Avengers film
opens on April 27th it has all your
favorites including the crew from
Wakanda this is gonna be massive and we
were exclusively on set this is d-day
man people don't understand what they're
walking into at this movie so much
happening more than 60 Marvel characters
converge for infinity war well let's
start with the original romance Tony
Stark and Pepper Potts have patched
things up
he and Pepper have clearly resolved
their differences the way you resolve
those differences as you shack up
together long term Robert and I
definitely work very well together but I
don't think you can construct that
chemistry it's something that is there
or it's not fans are getting what they
wanted Chris Pratt and his guardians of
the galaxy joined the battle let's talk
about this plan tears I think it's good
except it sucks so let me do the plan
and that way it might be really good Wow
Chris Pratt sarcasm sarcasm Robert
Downey jr. sarcasm senior I think they
do a good job of taking you know and
sprinkling those guys around yeah this
is a giant spectacle it has cameos from
every major character that's existed in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for this
one epic two-part battle epic because
Josh Brolin plays one of the greatest
super villains the Avengers have ever
seen tell me his name again
Dennis sheer force and strength is
something that none of the Avengers of
anyone in the MC universe has ever
really encountered before the Infinity
stones is what he's going for he's going
for all power one Infinity stone is in
the Black Panther world of Wakanda where
a good part of the action takes place my
Scarlett said she was so pumped to have
you to have brie Larson like more
females in this world now I come in like
it's not just me I come in with an arm
she has a farm who looks just like me
the walk-on does seem to be shot we
really brought there what kind of
culture it's in a moment
[Music]
you